hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wild game that uh only features
13 moves it's from the 2006 gibraltar
masters it's english grand master peter
k wells against the latvian grand master
or also spanish grand master alexei
sheriff and
13 moves that's it 13 moves in a
classical game and it features an
opening that's used quite a lot and a
line that's been used quite a lot so i
thought we'd mix it up a little bit
since the
uh videos during the usgs championship
those classical games were extremely
long and you know just the difficult
difficult to to handle uh so i thought
we you know break the pattern with a
nice
uh interesting one uh and also i would
just like to invite everyone tomorrow at
8 30 central european time we're gonna
be having a live stream and the leeches
tournament everyone is invited uh the
link is in the description below i will
be uh joined by the ceo of cake defy uh
julian hospin uh we're gonna be uh
streaming it together you know enjoying
some chess
and taking some questions from you guys
so make sure to be here if you can make
it and also if you can play it uh that
being said uh let's check out the game
and my board is looking weird let me
just fix that
there we go nice looking board uh so
peter k wells uh versus alexa shear of
white opens with d4 uh we have knight to
f6 uh and bishop to g5 the trombosky
attack in this game uh if you've ever
felt uh or you know uh
fell victim to the trompowsky uh you
might use this um at your advantage so
here we have c5 attacking the central d4
pawn this is all very standard uh white
gives up the bishop to mess up the black
spawn structure we have g captures on f6
and now advances the pawn all to d5 uh
sort of stifling black's uh position but
now we have queen to b6 black develops
the queen with tempo the b2 pawn is now
hanging
uh and the queen to c1 so very very rare
opening where uh both players are you
know uh moving their queens very early
on in the opening so here we have f5 uh
sure makes room for this bishop to come
alive you want to bring this bishop to
g7 go after the b dupont but also you
might play bishop to h6 just try and
kick away that queen from the c1 square
so c4 are just strengthening your
position in the center and now bishop to
h6 attacking the queen here
and now e3 uh we don't want to move our
queen of course we don't want to give up
our pawn but now shirov continues with
f4 and the shiro if you've seen his
games anywhere we've covered quite a lot
of them on this channel uh does not shy
away from complicated uh positions in
fact he thrives in them he you know it's
uh
uh you know just uh it just comes very
natural to him uh so here we have e
captures an f4 you don't want to wait
for f captures on e3 looks really odd to
allow this so we have e captures on f4
and now sheriff plays bishop captures on
f4 now if the queen captures we're going
to capture the pawn here on g on b2 so
white of course allows this we have
queen captures on f4 queen captures on
b2 and now knight to e2 and this is
still a very well known theory for those
who have studied this line of the
trompowsky the rook
cannot be saved so of course you just
prepared to bring this knight to c3 and
sort of trap the black queen you cannot
win the black queen but you can trap her
for a little bit so queen captures on a1
knight e to c3 and now there is a very
important move that black needs to play
in this position and that is d6 you want
to play d6 and then you want to play
rook to g8 that's important if you guys
play this or you know something like
this uh but in the game uh maybe
sherwood just forgot to play d6 he
played queen to b2 interestingly d6 was
played many times like for example in
the world blitz championship 2013 uh
between nikita vitugo and uh uh daniel
dubo dubo played d6 that game also a
sharp one ended in a draw but here we
have the early queen to b2 and now yeah
this is a problem now i'm going to ask
you guys to pause the video here and try
to find the uh just you know a winning
move for white here while i give you a
couple of seconds
uh yeah and also uh queen to b2 was a
new move so yeah it is as of this move
did we have a completely new game so for
those of you who were able to find it uh
congratulations on just completely
destroying black uh and for those of you
who just want to enjoy it is pawn to d6
this is already move 12 and we said that
the game ends on move 13 so what what
happens here well the problem is you
don't really have a good move here if
you capture e captures and d6 we're just
going to play bishop to d3 and now what
do you play uh you might try a
developing move knight to c6 we're just
gonna castle and this is unplayable what
can you do here yeah you can develop
this bishop you can't push your pawns uh
rook to e1 check is coming it's just a
disgusting position for black this is
instant resign so another thing after
this move you could decide to advance
the pawn but this isn't much better
queen to f6 we're threatening checkmate
and we just you know queen captures an
h8 if you somehow stop checkmate
now for example queen c1 check knight to
d1 and now we can castle the safety
preventing both threats of checkmate in
the queen captures on h8 but now just h4
and there's really nothing you can do
against rook h3 rook to g3 that's game
over even if you some some like queen
captures on b1 prepare to bring the
queen back you simply do not have enough
uh material now for example queenie for
check we're gonna block with rook to e3
and now after you finally play the queen
here we're gonna play rook to g3 win the
queen and that's it for example captures
captures and black does have some
material for the queen but all of the
pieces are completely undeveloped and
white simply has to play some like
knight e3 knight g4 knight g4 knight h3
checkmate or you can bring the bishop
into the game you can really win this
game in any way you like so you can't
really advance the pawn you can't touch
the pawn on d6 so here sheriff played
queen to c2
but now there's one really big problem
with this move again pause the video
here and try to find it the only winning
move for white while i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it for the second time congratulations
on finding the only move that wins and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is queen to e3 uh this is
what uh
peter wells played and he was in this
position on move 13 that alexei shiro
resigned the game as uh there is nothing
you can do here to defend this position
the problem is uh if you play something
like e6 it's uh doesn't really do all
that much we're going to play bishop to
d3 the only square now available for the
queen is the b to square all of these
squares are covered you have to play
queen to b2 and now we're going to play
knight to b5 and this is just ugly for
example if knight c7 checking the 8th
queen to g5 it's game over if
okay maybe maybe you can block still
with f6 but
it's really really ugly for example king
f8 we're going to play queen to h6 with
check and now even if the queen blocks
we can just trade here captures captures
and after knight to c7 we win the rook
and that's it we want to look back we're
up material whatever black plays knight
captures here we're up a piece now
and we're just you know nicely gonna
bring the the knight back and that's it
there's nothing you can do to
survive this and if you don't play e6 if
you play something like knight to c6
which is also possible you might defend
against checkmate this way we still play
bishop d3 queen b2 and now this very
nasty bishop to e4 we remove the
defender of the e7 square and then we
again want to threaten checkmate and if
knight to d4 kind of preventing this now
we just castle and again the position is
just so disgusting for black if for
example knight to e6 uh we can capture
on e7 if king captures knight d five
check the other knight is coming here
and it's just uh unplayable uh
everything is completely undeveloped and
this is just uh you know so disgusting
to even think about playing that after
queen to e3 should have just resigned
the game
so there we have it a nice 13 move
miniature hope you guys enjoyed that one
is i thought it'd be
you know
fun after those games uh
from the usgs championship that were
really really exhausting those videos
were very long uh and uh maybe you know
to take uh a moment's breath here uh
swam once again hope you guys enjoyed it
do join us tomorrow for the live stream
and for the tournament the link is in
the description below or everyone is
welcome to join uh i would like to thank
charles karen david farney tom daryl and
michael schmidle and barry sertal for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else is happening in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day